no one disputes
in this case that this case is a
horrible tragedy it really is i mean
joss castellano who is the
the young man who passed away in this
case
was high school buddies with
mr ferraro they've known each other for
years they went through the police
academy together
they became very close in the police
academy close to the extent that that
when they both became
certified law enforcement officers they
were partnered together so this is not
just a best friend that passed away this
is a police partner
that that that a police force partner
that passed away a fellow police officer
and
both individuals have looked into both
individuals
police background
they were both considered excellent
police officers they were both
considered
they don't have any disciplinary
problems with the police department
they've never been written up for any
kind of abusive conduct on on any
citizens in fact
in some of the facebook posts that have
been surrounding this case there have
been people that have been posting
of all races
saying how
robert ferraro has helped their child or
kept their child out of a life of crime
or helped them join
the boys club that kind of stuff
so they're both they were
they're both excellent officers
and
it is a huge huge devastating loss
that's being felt regardless of what
what ends up happening in this case
regardless of that
it's a huge loss for everyone obviously
the castellano family
and but but
it's just devastating for for
robert ferraro to have lost his best
friend and partner in this way